we are multiplying 10 a minus 3 by the
entire polynomial 5a squared plus 7a
minus 1. so to do this we can just do
the distributive property we can
distribute this entire polynomial this
entire trinomial times each of these
terms we could have 5a squared plus 7a
minus 1
times
times 10a times 10a
and then 5a squared plus 7a minus 1
times negative 3. so let's just do that
so if we have so let me just write it
out so we could have
5 let me write it this way 10 a
10
we could have 10
a
times 5 a squared plus 7 a minus 1
that's that right over here
and then we can have
minus 3
times 5 a squared plus 7a minus 1 and
that is this distribution right over
here and then we can simplify it
10 a times 5a squared 10 times 5 is 50.
a times a squared is a to the third
10 times 7 is 70.
a times a is a squared 10 a times
negative 1 is negative
10 a
then we distribute this negative 3 times
all of this negative 3 times 5 a squared
is negative 15
a squared
negative 3 times 7a is negative 21a
negative 3 times negative 1 is positive
3. and now we can try to merge like
terms this is the only a to the third
term here so this is 58 to the third
i'll just rewrite it
now we have two a squared terms we have
70 a squared minus 15 or negative 15 a
squared so we can add these two terms
70 of something minus 15 of that
something is going to be 55
of that something so plus
plus 55
a squared
and then we also have two a terms we
have this negative 10 a and then we have
this negative 21a so if we go negative
10 minus 21 that is negative 31.
that is negative 31a
so that is negative 31a
and then
we want a negative 31a and then finally
we only have one constant term over here
we have this positive three so plus
three and we are done